hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
with the month of Halloween right around
the corner
I found it only fitting to talk about
something truly scary that's right
the fear of the subconscious we have
orgies in summer of 1999 legendary
filmmaker Stanley Kubrick's final film
premiere just after he died eyes wide
shut incredibly hyped with its teeming
marketing audience reactions seemed to
be mainly this no is that well a hit
with critics Eyes Wide Shut
mostly alienated audiences who saw it as
nothing but slow artsy porn and a leavin
the porn part at the time seemed to be
edited out so you don't even get that
going for you years later after all the
hype has died down can it be true in
Stanley Kubrick's final masterpiece just
glorified TNA as opposed to his other
glorified TNA that at least had a point
well I may be an old fashion critic who
reads too deeply into disturbed
perverted Minds but I do have an
interpretation to figure out what the
movies about let's look at the basic
story will and al is played by Tom
Cruise and Nicole Kidman seem like a
normal well-off couple but one night
things go south went under obviously
some very bad Todd Ellis admits that she
would have given up everything just for
a night of lust with us say where she
saw years ago she also has a dream that
night that she was having sex with that
sailor and that she was doing it mainly
to hurt her husband she's never talked
like this before given a hints in the
past but this seems to obviously piss
off will obsessed over this he goes on a
journey to try and either one-up her by
sleeping with someone else or at the
very least achieving a similar mental
lust with another woman he sneaks into a
sexual den of holy fuckery where
powerful people wear masks and sleep
with whoever they want but when he's
discovered his life is threatened but
saved by a young woman who sacrifices
herself because he saved her life
earlier that as he tries to look for
answers his simple world begins to
crumble as he's follow threatened and
apparently endangered or corrupt
many of the people around him he's
finally given an out when one of the
people at the masked ball of holy fuck
'no says that everything was just a ploy
to scare him into not revealing the
truth about their sexcapades suspicious
but still possible will decides to
accept the excuse and eventually comes
clean to his wife about everything they
decide to put behind the ugly experience
and forget it ever happened
trying to live the happy life they know
they want for themselves and each other
after doing one very important thing of
course hey what the hell did I just
watch when I first saw this movie I
didn't know what to think of it I loved
the style and the imagery but I had no
idea what it was trying to get across
everything started to come together
though when I asked myself one simple
question do Alison we'll love each other
I've asked this question to a few people
who have seen the movie you'd be
surprised how many different answers
there are some say yes they never
technically went with anyone else and
every couple is going to have their
moments of doubt this was just a really
ugly it'll be a bizarre experience that
they're loved all them through but
others would say no there's too many
issues being ignored and too much pain
and vengeance the two half or one
another even the line about living
together forever seems to frighten Alice
we're awake now a long time to come
forever
[Music]
you frightens me but others say that's a
normal scary idea for lots of people and
the anger that comes out is normal when
you are invested and cares so much for
one another I started to work backwards
on this question of whether or not they
loved each other because clearly our
main couple wasn't going to take the
time to find the real answer kind of
like how will isn't taking the time to
find the real answer to a possible crime
scene wait a minute
the same way he has an out from all this
misery even though a lot of bad stuff
could have gone down is pretty similar
to how they're taking it out for their
relationship that may also have some
alarming things to address it's even
done in this very romantic fantasy like
setting like happily ever after this is
what it's supposed to be surrounded by
toys and fairy tales and smiling faces
it's like they're suggesting their happy
ending it's right around the corner just
go ahead and forget all the misery it's
kind of like how will tells Alice that
the dream she had is nothing more than a
dream nothing to worry about
[Music]
but she is worried she hates that these
thoughts are in her head isn't love
supposed to be emotional comfort and
support why would she have such terrible
vengeful thoughts about her soulmate the
one she chose to live the rest of her
life with is that something to be
concerned about or is the mind just
really complex and would go to these
dark places anyway does love go as deep
as your subconscious again some would
say obviously yes while others would say
obviously no love it's a compromise with
hurdles and complex feelings but at what
point do you say love has nothing to do
with certain parts of the brain the
brain can be a dark place and obviously
it's gonna go to some creepy areas that
doesn't mean it's bad right at what
point does the subconscious become
conscious when love is involved kind of
a blurry line between the dream world
and reality isn't it actually the whole
film kind of is everything is very
dreamlike the blurry colors the hazy
lights the dark shadows he'll the masked
ball scene is something right out of a
nightmare with scary faces in the dark
exposing you at your very core he's even
asked to take off his clothes though
they can do
god knows what to it remove your clothes
tell me please remove your clothes or
would you like us to do it for you how
many drinks have you had were you were
naked and exposed to everyone well that
were actually dreams it's kind of like
that night he chose to enter the world
of his sexual subconscious trying to
figure out what he really wants but then
the next day when he's more awake
reality sets in the harsh consequences
of his actions now suddenly seem to take
hold
it's contrasting reality with dreams and
where the line should be drawn between
the instinct of sex and the instinct of
love which seems to be more and more
blurred the harder you look at it
even the title Eyes Wide Shut at first I
thought it was just kind of a cool artsy
name but when you really think about it
what's it a play on eyes wide open
meaning you focus intensely on what's in
front of you well then what would you
focus intensely on when your eyes are
closed
what can you focus on when your eyes are
closed oh yeah your dreams even will
seems to backtrack in the end
emphasizing that there's simple
understanding of love and giving of
oneself goes deeper than what's on the
surface that like you says just a train
the way this all started seemed to stem
from a different mindset as well with
both of them getting high and not
thinking about what's socially
acceptable to themselves or others their
minds are just free to do and say
whatever they want the whole movie seems
to focus on that unraveling layers and
journeying through the shadows to find
the truth of what it means to give
yourself fully both mind and body to
another person the more I looked at this
film the more I realized it was bringing
up questions that every couple should
discuss how deep does love go how deep
should it go what's the cutoff point
rather than searching for answers though
our leaves like many couples choose to
ignore it and move on with their lives
is this making things better or worse it
seems like they're ignoring a lot of
important issues but that this
time forgive-and-forget nobody's going
to be perfect right like many great
films it doesn't answer it for you it
just gives you the questions worth
thinking about
it asks what connection love has to
everything sex emotions even your
deepest inner thoughts that you keep
hidden ice white shut exposes that
secret place and asks you to draw
conclusions from it it's a film that
dives into what it means to go from
being me into being me and when you have
to be ready to explore if you're willing
to make the full commitment so yes
someone could look at this and just see
a pretentious porno which maybe was all
part of Stan Lee's evil plan spend lots
of money just to confuse and piss people
off that would be financially brilliant
right me hahahaha but for me I can't
help but think these artistic choices
are more than just coincidence that
there is something deeper than the
surface of the story just like there's
something deeper than the surface of a
relationship if you're going for some
high end TNA you're probably going to be
disappointed but if you're willing to
look deeper inside the film who knows
you might just find something a little
deeper in your own relationship
[Music]
or maybe the lesson of the whole thing
is masked orgies are a great place to
meet chicks
either way I know what I'm doing tonight
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember so
you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]